richard has served in the
administration's of four presidents in
2003 became president on the nonpartisan
Council on Foreign Relations he authored
or edited 13 books on American foreign
policy
his most recent is a world in disarray
American foreign policy and the crisis
of the old order the book is the focus
of a new vice documentary it explores
major foreign policy challenges facing
the United States documentary debuts
Friday on HBO Richard Haass joins us now
welcome talk morning it's good to have
you here we'll talk about the video I
mean the the documentary on HBO as well
as the book but first this there is this
me second meeting we're making what
should we say about it how do we assess
the fact that the president gets up
there walks over and sits next to
vitamin Putin and has a conversation in
a room that they've been having dinner
in other context that may be comfortable
but here you know we don't understand
why mr. Trump has had this benign
attitude towards Putin in Russia for the
last several years the fact that this
meeting he went into without talking
points without his own interpreter
without a note-taker after not having an
NSC officially on the meeting I mean
some it just went over to talk to him
they talked for an hour but well okay
that in view of every but I don't think
we've ever talked for an hour I mean
ours a long time you can get a lot done
in an hour and again it's not taking
place in a vacuum we don't understand
what has motivated this president who
hasn't staked out a lot of harm what do
you see the answers look like we can
then we're in the land of speculation
about what be Modi I don't want to go
there I don't know but he hasn't
explained it and it's an anomaly and
this just we're uncomfortable because we
don't know what his agenda is everything
how is Russia affecting what you talked
about in the terms of this world in
disarray Russia's a real problem
it's in one way it's a small country
we're talk about a 140 million people
one-tenth the size of China it has no
real economy it's just largely only gas
but Russia's become a spoiler they've
used force in Europe they've
reintroduced military force in
geopolitics into Europe they committed
what's honestly atrocities in Syria they
interfered in our election other
elections using cyber so
it's become a real spoiler they have to
find themselves in some ways in
opposition to the United States one of
the reasons this world is moving in the
wrong direction it's because of mr.
Putin's Russia part of part of Putin's
moves you also described are are fueled
by a lack of American leadership
absolutely then the world didn't just
turn out to be a fairly good place for
the last 70 years of course the United
States led these alliances built these
international institutions was there and
without us the world is not some
self-organizing system and Russia China
but also other people like Isis groups
like that are filling this space because
the United States is pulling back and
what's so odd I can't think of another
time in history when a great power
voluntarily in some ways abdicated its
position and created a geopolitical
vacuum so having read your book in this
documentary you seem to be indicted
Obama for that exactly I think it began
under President Obama what we rented
Obama I think historians will define by
as much weight he didn't do in some ways
george w bush overreached in the Middle
East in Iraq President Obama was in many
ways than an overreaction and under
reached in many parts of the world
taking US forces out of Iraq not getting
involved in Syria and mr. Trump is is
his own strange amalgam but he's not an
isolationist but he clearly doesn't
believe in many of the institution's and
many of the standing structures he
inherited from trade to alliances and
the rest of the world is beginning to
learn how to live without us our friends
are basically saying hey we've got to
look out for ourselves so history is
gaining momentum in ways we need China
filling the vacuum China can't fill the
vacuum by itself because it just simply
isn't that open it's more worried about
the perpetuation of the Communist Party
and all that at home but China Charlie
is in part filling the vacuum whether
it's its new infrastructure initiatives
its new trade initiatives China's
because is filling in part the American
space but there's no one not China not
Russia not Europe who can fill the shoes
of the United States the alternative to
the kind of world we've had of the
us-led world will be in nobody little
world and it'll be a Messier world well
I would have all the world know this
down if President Obama had been more
aggressive towards Russia Russia would
now and during his administration have
been less aggressive is what you're
saying
I believe for example
I did Ukraine with defensive arms which
every person and in his administration
as best I can tell favored but the
president didn't I think mr. Putin would
have seen less opportunity there if the
United States has been more active in
Syria I don't believe mr. Putin would
have been able to waltz in and get this
extraordinary return on a limited
investment so let's talk resident Obama
did warn the president about was North
Korea let me ask you about that because
in your book you talk about how
sanctions at this point are not enough
what do you see if anything in this
president's policy towards North Korea
that gives you signs of hope I think
he's done one thing that's different
which is really put North Korea front
and center and Hillary Clinton might
have done the same thing to be honest
made this the number one national
security threat we face put China on
notice that we simply can't continue to
allow this to drift what I'd like to see
him is try negotiations I don't know if
they'd succeed to put a ceiling on North
Korea's missiles and nuclear weapons if
that doesn't work though we're gonna
face a really consequential choice
either we're going to live with it what
they have with their ability to threaten
us what we're gonna have to use military
force against them either one has
tremendous consequences for the
character of the world we live in you
also write in the book the disarray at
home is inextricably linked to disarray
in the world how so well lots of ways
one is the example we said who would
want to emulate American democracy the
day after we have the health care
debacle we can't deal with our national
debt how can we pressure China on North
Korea if China is one of the two most
two largest holders of American debt so
what we're beginning to see is our
inability to govern ourselves at home to
deal with everything from infrastructure
to our debt to tax policy is reducing
the appeal of the American model we have
fewer resources available for national
security and we're more vulnerable the
only area I think we become less
vulnerable Noora is an energy
interestingly enough that was something
that happened because of local drillers
it didn't happen because of government I
think we've got to face the fact that
our government isn't working Richard
Haass always good to have you here the
books great and the documentary is
really emotional as well thank you so
much